difficult to be an artist in europe
whether it's for public performance or
broadcasting right many artists like
manuel conderos based in belgium use
copyright collectives to license work
and collect royalties on their behalf
the eu's recorded music market is worth
some six billion euros
using multiple copyright collectors for
different rights and across member
states can't be easy there are some 250
copyright collectors across the eu manu
uses sabam in belgium
meps have been working on a new law to
better manage collectives and to improve
multi-territorial licensing of music the
draft report was approved by a new page
in the legal affairs committee on
tuesday
online music platforms like itunes or
spotify are also a great way for artists
to get a bigger fan base worldwide and
bigger paychecks in future
music providers can more easily buy
a mixed aperture of music
and they can defuse it in many countries
worldwide
after passing the first test
negotiations with member states are
expected to start after the summer break